[Música]
[Aplausos]
soy yo tecnólogo de plantas pero hoy
vengo hablarles de sexo
si de sexo de uno de los organismos más
importantes de nuestro planeta
cuando yo me refiero a ellos en este
sentido yo los clasificó de manera
simple como pluris sexuales porque
porque tienen una gran variedad de
maneras de tener sexo y de esto
precisamente voy a hablarles pero en el
sentido estricto de la reproducción
los órganos sexuales masculinos y
femeninos de estos organismos están
siempre contenidos en una estructura
sexual y todos estos organismos no
solamente tienen una estructura sexual
pueden tener 210 100 o más estructuras
sexuales por lo tanto van a tener 10
siendo más órganos sexuales masculinos y
órganos sexuales femeninos imagínense
entonces la cantidad de sexo que éstos
tienen
una de las primeras variantes es que
aproximadamente el 70% de estos son
hermafroditas
esto significa que en su estructura
sexual están contenidos el órgano
masculino y el órgano femenino pero
aunque sean en más freddy estás hay
algunas variantes entre ellos hay
hermafroditas que tienen la estructura
sexual con ambos órganos pero también
desarrollan estructuras sexuales sólo
con el órgano masculino y otros que son
hermafroditas pero que desarrollan
también estructuras con el órgano
femenino por lo tanto los primeros se
comportan como hermafroditas y machos y
los otros como hermafroditas y hembras
pero además hay otra variante
interesante es que en el mismo individuo
desarrollan estructuras sexuales con
ambos órganos con el órgano masculino y
con el órgano femenino
a esto se le llama obligamos pueden
tener sexo consigo mismo de estructura
estructura y con todo lo que se les
ponga enfrente
si generalmente con los de al lado con
los que están cerca con los que están
lejos y con los que están muy lejos pero
incluso kilómetros de distancia esto si
tienen sexo real a distancia
y no sexo virtual como algunos otros
individuos
en general estos organismos tienen
diferentes preferencias sexuales así
digo yo por ejemplo hay algunos
hermafroditas que prefieren ser machos
durante la mañana y hembras por la tarde
su preferencia es en el día o viceversa
ser machos por la mañana y hembras por
la tarde
pero también hay otros organismos que
pueden así lo podría decir cambiar de
sexo con la edad
nacen hembras se desarrollan y maduran
sexualmente como machos o al revés
pueden hacer como machos y maduran
sexualmente como hembras como ven son
diferentes las variaciones sexuales que
estos organismos nos presentan
quizás muchos de ustedes ya saben de qué
organismos estoy hablando pero por favor
no lo digan a los que no lo saben
todavía ya que hay otra variante que
quizás no es tan interesante porque es
la más común porque es como nosotros
pero aparte les voy a hablar de un
sentido que hay en la relación del sexo
de estos organismos y nosotros primero
hablaré de esa variación en donde los
individuos tienen en su estructura
sexual los órganos sexuales separados es
decir hay individuos solo con
estructuras con órganos sexuales
masculinos a los que le llamamos machos
y otros son los que tienen en las
estructuras sexuales los órganos
femeninos y les llamamos hembras
estos solamente pueden reproducirse con
el sexo opuesto pero también con los de
al lado con los que están lejos y con
los que están muy lejos
en todos estos organismos en general
hermafroditas machos y hembras todas las
variantes una vez que se reproducen que
tienen sexo obtienen su fruto sexual que
finalmente es para la descendencia como
cualquier organismo la estructura sexual
junto con los órganos sexuales
masculinos y femeninos desaparecen o se
mueren
entonces son organismos que después de
que ocurre eso quedan sin sexo
son asexuales sin sus unidades
reproductivas
y bueno les puedo hablar de varias
formas que ocurre esto en estos
organismos
en algunos organismos la madurez sexual
ocurre al mes o en meses de haber nacido
pero en estos una vez que tienen sexo
los individuos generalmente mueren
algunos les ocurre al año y otros en dos
años crecen sin unidades reproductivas
al año siguiente las producen
y después mueren pero también hay
algunas especies que requieren muchos
años para madurar sexualmente por
ejemplo hay especies que tardan 50 75 o
100 años en tener esas estructuras
reproductivas
y tienen sexo por primera vez y mueren
tanto tiempo esperar para tener sexo
única vez y morir
de verdad todas estas la tristeza no la
primera vez y mueren pero lo hacen por
una gran causa lo hacen por pp perpetuar
su descendencia
la reproducción en estos organismos la
verdad es compleja
sin embargo como se los acabo de
describir es muy fácil de entender y
todos la conocemos este proceso es el
que conocemos como polinización
hablé de tener sexo pues es lo que
implica la polinización de estas
estructuras que van a tener unidades
reproductivas el andro se o que es en el
caso de masculino y el gineceo en el
caso del femenino ambas estructuras
están contenidas en la flor
las flores son las responsables de tener
estas unidades reproductivas para que
ocurran todas estas variantes sexuales y
si cuando dije que estos organismos
tienen 12 10 100 o más estructuras
sexuales pues son las plantas las que
tienen 110 100 o más flores y muchas de
estas plantas cuando se reproducen por
única vez mueren o desaparecen o mueren
las estructura estructuras reproductivas
y hay muchas plantas que requieren de
muchos años para tener su sistema de
reproducción hay especies que pueden
toda su vida tener sexo reproducirse y
producir su descendencia hay ejemplos de
esto de individuos de cientos y de miles
de años
lo que les acabo de dar en esta charla
es obviamente el sexo de las plantas
la reproducción como ya lo comenté es un
sentido en un sentido para la producción
de alimentos es muy importante ya que
nos dan todos estos frutos y todas estas
partes que nos dan alimento no sólo las
plantas son importantes para nosotros
como alimento sino también para muchos
otros organismos y además son el nicho
el hábitat de casi todos los organismos
en el planeta
los frutos en este caso son el producto
del sexo y son los encargados de guardar
las unidades esenciales las semillas
para la propagación de esta descendencia
cuando ustedes tengan en sus manos una
flor sin pena pueden
buscar estas estructuras sexuales para
que vean si son hermafroditas si son
machos si son hembras o son todas estas
variantes que yo les acabo de mencionar
quien de ustedes no se ha comido una
rica quesadilla con flor de calabaza
acompañada con un agua fresca de jamaica
de flores de jamaica y de postre unos
amigos en almíbar
pues se han comido la estructura sexual
junto con los órganos masculinos y
femeninos de una planta
lo sabía bueno todos nos comemos los
frutos las manzanas las peras las
naranjas semillas como almendras
cacahuetes y pistaches que son el
producto del sexo de las plantas
cuando ustedes o yo tomo un ramo de
flores de rosas y se las doy a mi pareja
sexual
de manera subliminal le estamos diciendo
toma mi amor
estas estructuras sexuales con sus
órganos masculinos y femeninos gracias
[Aplausos]